Harvey Weinstein's former assistant at
Miramax is breaking her non-disclosure
agreement and revealing his alleged
sexual harassment Zelda Perkins told the
Financial Times at Weinstein requested a
massage while in his underwear she also
claims that he asked her to be in the
room while he took a bath and often
tried to pull her into bed when she woke
him up Perkins and a colleague split a
settlement with Miramax of about 425
thousand dollars and signed a
nondisclosure agreement back in 1998
Miramax is not commenting and says that
the current owners were not involved in
the company at that time Harvey
Weinstein has denied all allegations of
non-consensual sex CBS News legal
analyst Ricky cleamen joins us at the
table to discuss hello Ricky let's talk
about Zelda Perkins breaking the
nondisclosure agreement what does that
mean and who does that hurt now we have
to look at the fact that there are two
types of non-disclosure agreements and
if either of them are broken there's a
possibility of damages we all basically
sign a nondisclosure agreement and a
company that says that if we leave a
company that we are not going to
disparage that company we're not going
to give away trade secrets we're not
gonna say bad things we'll put that to
one side now let's look at the sexual
harassment sexual abuse possibly even
sexual assault non-disclosure agreements
so what happens in those is two people
the perpetrator and the victim agree to
a contract and what they say is the
woman will use woman for the sake of
conversation the woman gets the money
but she must remain quiet she must never
say anything and the company may or may
not have to disclose that agreement and
the perpetrator or the company pays the
money now what happens to Zelda Perkins
if you violate a confidentiality
agreement you've broken a contract so
you might have to pay the money back and
there might be clauses where you have to
pay damage okay lots of people sign
non-disclosure agreements if you sign a
nondisclosure agreement and you are
sexually harassed or assaulted what are
your rights you do have rights we don't
think that in any way a
non a confidentiality agreement also
known as a nondisclosure agreement
totally silences you because of the
court system perfect example Bill Cosby
an Andrea constant Andrea constant who
was the victim who testified against
Bill Cosby in the criminal trial she
kept her confidentiality agreement never
said a word to anyone once it was signed
but once a judge ordered her to testify
of course she can testify you also don't
have to say if I sign a confidentiality
agreement if I've gone to the police
first you're protected going to the
police first or the Equal Opportunity
Employment Commission first there comes
a point where you can also talk about
val cause you just can't talk about your
case but many people feel these NDA's
have been used to cover up a crime you
know to keep it silent well there you
cannot be paid to cover up a crime so
these become very touchy negotiations if
it's sexual assault you cannot be a
lawyer and advise someone that take the
money and don't go forward and prosecute
that's a crime but in the case with Bill
O'Reilly and Liz Weil the New York Times
has reported that that it was because he
allegedly sent gay porn to her and that
there was a non-consensual sexual
relationship isn't that a crime it may
or may not be a crime the thing is that
this is a private agreement between
lease Weill and Bill O'Reilly that were
given reason to believe happened and
your experience 32 million dollars is
that a unusually large son unusual takes
my breath away absolutely takes my
breath away would suggest what that she
had some sort of evidence or something
that was really yes of course and in
fact we know that they are supposed to
as part of that confidentiality griot
the question is what Roy what might be
afeared to give up thirty two million
dollars
you must have feared something but all
physical evidence supposed to be
destroyed those documents voicemails
texts anything that they might have had
thank you right ain't claimin thank you
so much